So the, the pros and cons of,
background subtraction.
It's very easy to implement.
It's easy to do in real time,
fast, and the background models
don't have to be constant.
They can change, so
we could sort of track that change.
The disadvantage,
of course, is, you know,
frame differencing is a real problem,
depending on how things move.
The median background can be
a high memory requirement,
we talked about keeping all that.
And of course, you have to
build a set these thresholds.
When does this basic approach fail?
Well it fails a lot of times when
we can't really touch that, but
one, one idea that has come up that has
really gotten a lot of play is that,
suppose your background
actually has a couple of
different things that might be in it,
right?
So, the example that, that I'll show
you in a minute you're looking at,
water and sometimes it's plain water,
and sometimes it's a specularity.
Or you might be looking at some areas
where there's some foliage, and
you might get, you know, one color from
the leaf, and one color from the thing
that's not so, so these pix, pixels
are essentially in the background.
They're twinkling between a couple
of different values, all right?
And that analysis was the basis of
a paper that's now very well known by
Chris Stauer and Eric Grimson on
doing adaptive background modeling.
And here, they're showing you
a couple different examples.
So we'll just do them,
one is the water here.
And the idea is that the water,
most of the time, it's kind of this dark
color and that's shown as this
distribution as sort of a low value.
This is you can think
of this as an RG space.
But when they get bright specularities,
you get this high value.
Likewise, this area where the door is,
well when the door is opened,
it's bright because it's light,
it's lit by the,
the, the light in the hall,
in the office.
But when the door is open,
it's much darker and it's over there.
So the idea is that there's
multiple values in the background.
So what they did was they said okay,
we're going to model the background
as a mixture of Gaussians.
That is, we're going to say that
the background could be made up
of a couple of different
distributions of intensities, and
we're going to learn
those distributions.
So if a pixel comes in,
if it comes from one of those Gaussians,
I'll say it's background.
And, if it isn't, if it's new, then
I'm going to say I think that's a new
object, I might hold on to it to
see if it becomes background, but
that's how you do the detection.
One of the cool things about that,
I'll tell you that early on when papers
like this were being done like I said,
people thought background
subtraction was sort of trivial.
I think this paper is one of the paper
that won the Longuet-Higgins prize for
being most cited ten years
after it was published,
because it just became a really
important piece of work.